[Musique]
les moustiques
ce travail
c'est ce que nous faisons en cette période de
la corde il n'y a pas d'autre travail aussi
[Musique]
puis la vie de l'homme amazonien
du châtaignier quand on arrive à
ramasser les châtaignes comme ça avec la pluie
Parfois, les pantalons subissent le mauvais temps
les costumes tombent comme si tu regardais les cartes
c'est dangereux il faut gagner
là sous la plante là quand ça vient
un fort coup de vent
[Musique]
ici maintenant oui quand c'est comme cette moitié
de la montagne la vipère
[Musique]
Ce n'est pas comme on dit qu'il gagne de l'argent mais
ils ont sacrifié
eh bien, sacrifie
[Musique]